nicky larson aussi c'est la mini la mini
rouge elle est là bas c'est très simple
on va prendre deux membres de l'équipe
de liquide actionne plus bien sûr car
elle qui est un petit peu l'homme fort
bien qu'elle ait fait pas le malin quand
tu te lèves la doller bois à côté de toi
fais gaffe quand même aux camélias mon
chéri d'amour et kamel choisi deux
membres de son équipe il est là et ce
qui est une fille de dents ou ses toiles
et une fille voilà on fait on fait m'a
donc elodie eux l'ont dit elodie écrit
enfin je crois de choix suffit mais nous
tarek d'accord le 20 août avec tarek est
très costaud je vais nager continent
dans ton truc je vous rappelle que les
perdants seront dans la mini et devons
affronter le parfum de la mort
johnny c'est le parfum de la mort c'est
pas le parfum de cupidon il reste 90
minutes
enfermé dans la mini alors que moi je
pense que tu devrais prendre christine
annoncé christine effort assez connaît
rien avec les signes d'espoir qui je
pense que tu es la plus sportive avec
géraldine non non je pense que c'est
francis à huy 3-2 chez ce cas c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais j'ai des bras de mouches
à bâle hervé les parents qui ont
carrément mardi de manier ça lui demande
jusqu alors attention ça va en trois
points d'accord on va pas discuter on va
faire en trois points d'accord d'abord
jean-mi entre tarek ma jambe me contre
tarek l'isi premier il saisit donc vous
êtes là d'accord et vous tapez d'accord
oui chef
non la braguette ouverte non je rigole
et surtout revoir à la baisse
on n'attend rien de bon attention
[Musique]
et bien pas de colère je regardais les
jambes et deux en arrière attention
derrière alors attention parce que ces
gens me fait 812 je me demande comment
on ferme et on ferme youssef et kamel 1
attention c'est parti
non mais bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime ce mec il arrivait pas pourquoi
je t'aime trois équipes alors pour le
club et pour l'équipe
bien sûr ça ne compte pas mais paula gm
duels elodie fontan contre francesca et
après il y aura kamel contrôle youssef
je peux pas l'oublier les bras dont je
fais un truc j'ai suffisamment son
footeux à la frontière
la cruche 4,76 à mal elodie donnent tous
passés de l'olivier vous pouvez donner
vos tickets des adjots pourrait revenir
à un point partout c'est à me le prendre
dans la tronche rapport à temps d'abord
elle est pas mal elle est pas mal allez
paris
[Musique]
ça va se jouer maintenant entre nous
c'est bon [ __ ] mais sa carrière ne
s'est décantée via la minuk et dehors
est ce que le réalisateur pour montrer
la mini puisque vous allez dans la mine
et dans un instant et vous allez être
aspergé du parfum de la mort le parfum
est dégueulasse vous serez vous serez je
vous le dis pendant une minute
enfermé dans la voiture d'accord le
parfum j'ai un petit échantillon du
parfum me dit non ça pue trop peu avant
de sortir des 22 10 981 youssef alesi
youssef attention elle fait pas comme
par ex ne passez pas à côté il y avait
du vent il y avait bien sûr ne restez
pas coté
ouais
oui je le sens bien
[Applaudissements]
attention quand même car el kamel c1 ne
me fait pas honte on se connaît depuis
des années - c'est franchement si c'est
un pote secte et mon frère j'ai beaucoup
parlé de toi tu ne fais pas en dessous
[Rires]
et à tous les prix sont garde jean
rachid et tous nous regarde youssef toi
tu as fait un beau score dans cette sale
temps pour monter avec toi ta gueule
mais imaginons une passe à côté ou un
truc comme ça lui je pense ça m'arrange
du lancement s'il passe jamais à côté du
regard nous car nous avions fait le
boulot
attention c'est pas les bâtiments camou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cb
j'étais sûr il a fait 8 168 800 gardes
836 contre 838 j'entends il a ripé 1
s'est passé à san mames est arrivé je
vous jure c'est passé bachiri avant
qu'on fasse bien sûr le siphon mis
partout par suite on va accueillir
quelqu'un qui fait une apparition dans
le film
franchement c'était quand tu t'es tu
t'es dit comment pourquoi tu avances à
dorothée pour ce rôle pas c'est archi
logique nous dans le scénario on l'avait
on avait écrit tout de suite qu'on
voulait dorothée après on savait pas si
à dire oui ou non
oui scénario l'a dit oui tout de suite
et on était comme des fous et bien
dorothée avec tout ce soit
justement et librement
ce n'est pas gênant
c
oh
[Musique]
oui c'est l'ordinateur
moi
où est passé mon bac
dorothée qui est avec nous alors je
crois que nos amis sont dans la voiture
dorothée sais pas si tu as vu toute
l'équipe de ton film a gagné toko
heureusement regarder son dans la
voiture là bas alors ils sont enfermés
dias et si ça sans merci
regardez l fallait pas perdre tout
simplement